so on the next line let's have a look at
this I have multiplying two complex
numbers together now when you multiply
numbers in polar form
that's why numbers in polar form you do
something to the moduli and you do
something to the I use what you do to
the module you multiply it you multiply
the bonds so there they are right there
so when I multiply them I'm just going
to get my dad what W okay so I
multiplied the mods what I did the
arguments I add them so you can see he
is one argument and he's the other one
when I add these together I'm gonna get
filled in minus five huh that's a good
sign
that's a good sign that we're headed in
the right direction so I've got here cos
of theta minus Phi right that's the sum
of their things plus I sine of theta
works fine think I need one more bracket
there we go so I've multiplied the first
pair they've come together which
thankfully for me is big enough from the
space on this line that I've been doing
the next one over here right again I'm
going to multiply them odds and the
arguments right coincidentally or not
I'm going to get ones in wonder we
guarantee and then what's the argument
for the new context that they're going
to be the product fun I see very good
because you can see that's positive and
that's thing it's reversed okay so let's
write that down
okay now this is really good very
promising let's pause and think back
where are we headed where are we going
we want look we've got mods in model use
we've got a few of them flying around
thumbs up
I've got theater - fine then we noticed
that these looked good and then we
computed these and Ernest hung their
backwards okay so these I'm gonna leave
where they are I'm gonna muck around
with these how can i muck around with
him adjust them so that I can get them
in the right facing the right direction
in the right order would you suggest
that I do okay so the first thing I
could do is pull this guy right or this
product fella out the front because I
know it's gonna be out the fun
eventually sauce to that huge square
bracket okay and then all this other
stuff I'll just highlight it this other
stuff is what gets left behind when I
factorize do you agree with that that's
a good step now I'm gonna write this
part here the first wee bit I'm gonna
leave this as it is because you remember
the angles aren't exactly the right
order that I want okay that's how long
I'm going to do here if I want to
distally theta minus 5 instead of I
might see enough what can I do
now I'm going to pull our memory back to
a trick that we used when we were
manipulating cause inside we're doing
another proof right there's a closet
sign I'm not just any functions they
have particular functions they have
symmetry built in it right now they
outlawed any even functions which ones
either okay good cause is even maybe you
want to even touch them for yourself
this time is even and this guy is on
right so what that tells me is that for
an even function f of X and F of
negative x odd the same right cuz that's
why you've got this symmetry like this
okay so I can just replace that guy I
could just replace it with that because
causes an even function I'm gonna say
that the second once I finish writing my
life okay so you can see what I've done
I could just switch those eggs around
beacause causes even what am I gonna
have to do here keep in mind there's a
negative sign yeah so what am i right
here
okay yeah very good so I've actually got
two negatives here so I'm gonna write
the first one which is already there -
and then I'm going to replace this thing
with why I should replace with since
sine is odd right which is minus I sine
theta minus Phi remember the reason I'm
doing this it's to get the angles in the
right order okay let's see if I've got
the right number records I think don't
use to be a big square one as I'm
finished okay do you see what I've done
so I should justify why I've done that
why I've done this switch and the
reasonable way I guess I'll leave it
since cause X is even when sine X is odd
okay that's the reason I can replace it
and now we kind of on the homestretch
have a look at what you got have a look
what's gonna happen to those cosine
times they go on right see this guy and
this guy by the way I recommend what
you're doing this when you've got lots
of canceling whether it's cancelling a
little numerator denominator or
canceling pluses and negatives I highly
recommend you underline those terms
rather than crossing them not because
it's clean I'm combining them but as a
marker I can still really not you've
written it's not like this is just like
been erased I can see how you're
combining them okay okay that's good
what about the signs what's gonna happen
to those yeah we get two of them on our
cuz you've got I sign anything you've
got a double main here I sign okay so
let's write this all out since there's
two of them I'm gonna have mod Z more W
times 2i sine theta minus five boy
that's simplified down what didn't it
okay
so even though this looks gross to write
out it was just temporary until we can
do some work on it this is a proof so I
just need to do one more thing before I
get to here that would you rephrase this
thing to make it very obvious
yeah pulled out a factor of four but a
factor for which will leave you with a
half in there
does that make sense so I'm gonna write
the four at the front
I guess I'll also write the I at the
front cuz the area the area doesn't have
an eye in it does it it should it
because it's a so I felt I at the front
so I've taken that guy out that leaves
me with a half one said well W Simon
yeah
my name is fire and I've run out of
space on my whiteboard but conveniently
I have already written the result I'm
gonna angry okay so that will be your
final line what do you think
how'd your brain go as you went through
that okay did you notice that a lot of
this was well not a lot of it but seeing
it past this forty minute and extension
one that was too unit I mean I know
we've dressed it up an extension to
language but it's just the area of
triangle what about in here there was
stuff with just like already met
functions all the times you see tree
expansions which again we've learn
through extension one those combine all
of those with stuff like conjugate how
did that work what about real imaginary